tomorrow is the national day of
reflection and Marie Curie LED
initiative bringing together communities
across the UK to remember family friends
neighbors and colleagues we have lost
will the Prime Minister join me in
thanking Stoke City Council for
supporting my call for a post box to
heaven in car Mountainside cemetery and
on the second anniversary of the tragic
death of my constituent two-year-old
Harper Lee vanthorpe who swallowed a
button battery will he thank her
courageous mother Stacy for leading the
campaign to raise awareness of the
dangers of button batteries and will he
back my call for legislation to ensure
greater product safety
Mr Mr Speaker of course I join honorable
friend thanking Stoke City Council I'm
very sorry to hear of our police tragic
case and my thoughts are with her
friends and family and particularly her
mother Stacy and we are aware of the
concerns about button batteries the law
is very clear that products available in
the UK must be safe the office for
product and safety standards as
published guidance on exactly this for
manufacturers and is working with a
child accident prevention trust to
educate parents and Child Care
Professionals on button baton safety
this is the opposition
uh thank you Mr Speaker today we
remember the innocent lives lost six
years ago in a terror attack on
Westminster Bridge
amongst those tragically killed was PC
Keith Palmer who sacrificed his life to
protect others police officers up and
down the country worked tirelessly every
day to keep us safe and we thank them
for that
but as we saw this week those Brave
officers are being let down Dame Louise
Casey found institutional homophobia
misogyny and racism in the metropolitan
police
I accept those findings in full
does the prime minister
Mr Speaker I joined with the honorable
gentleman paying tribute to PC Palmer
and indeed all the other police officers
who have lost their lives serving and
those who do so much to keep us safe I
was appalled Mr Speaker to read the
descriptions of the abhorrent cases of
officers who have betrayed The public's
trust and abused their powers and let me
be clear it is and was unacceptable and
should never have happened we have taken
a series of steps already and the
government will also now work with the
mayor and the Metropolitan commissioner
to ensure that culture standards and
behavior all improve at the heart of
this matter other people whose lives
have been ruined by what has happened
and I know the whole house will agree
with me that it is imperative that the
Met works hard to regain the trust of
the people it is privileged to serve
I take it from that answer that the
Prime Minister does accept the Casey
findings in full including the
institutional failures because nobody
reading the Casey report can be left in
any doubt about how serious this is and
doubt for a second that it's restricted
to the Met
the report lays bare how those unfit to
join the police are aided by Patchwork
vetting systems that leave the door open
if the government-backed Labor's plan
for proper mandatory National vetting we
could end the farce that sees different
Police recruitment standards in
different forces
will he back that plan so we can make
Speedy progress prime minister Mr
Speaker there's no need to back that
pound because we're already taking
action to tackle the issues that are
raised in the Casey report and it was
actually two months ago it was two
months ago that I met with Dame Louise
Casey and the Metropolitan commissioner
and we introduced a series of measures
for instance the College of policing is
currently updating the statutory code of
practice for police officer vetting that
all forces legally have to follow all
police forces are in the process of
checking their offices against the
police National Database and in weeks
Her Majesty's independent inspectorate
will report back on their re-inspection
of all forces vetting procedures now
these steps of course won't undo the
terrible damage that have been
previously committed but we owe this
action and more to the victims and
survivors to ensure that such tragedies
never happen again
well the problem with the prime
minister's answer is what he's referring
to isn't mandatory how can it possibly
be right to have different standards for
recruitment in different police forces
no wonder the Casey report criticize
what she calls the government's
hands-off attitude to policing over the
last 13 years but let's call it what it
really is sheer negligence
the report also exposes chronic failures
by the police with rape cases with
officers using and I quote overstuffed
or broken fridges containing the rape
kits of victims on his watch rape
charges are 1.6
yet the government still hasn't backed
Labor's plan to have proper high quality
rape and serious sexual offenses units
in every police force why not
Mr Speaker what what Louise Casey also
says is that primary public
accountability of the Met sits with the
mayor of London
[Applause]
she described that relationship between
the mayor and the Met as in her words
dysfunctional
[Applause]
when he stands up he will also confirm
to the house so he will take up these
matters with the labor mayor of London
so that he plays his part
he rape victims were treated by the
criminal justice system wasn't good
enough and that's why the government
published an ambitious rape review
action plan it's right that we've
extended operation sawteria across all
police forces in the country we've
tripled the number of independent sexual
violence advisors we've improved the
process of collecting phone evidence and
being cross-examined and since 2010
we've quadrupled funding for victim
support services that is a conservative
government doing everything we can to
SS
people are fed up to the back teeth with
a government that never takes
responsibility and just tries to blame
everyone they can shout if they're proud
if they're proud of the fact that nine
over 98 of rapists are never put before
if they want to shout about that that's
their record let them shout about it to
be ashamed of yourself the truth is
simple after 13 years of Tory government
crime is out of control and people are
paying the price
Before Christmas the BBC reported the
shocking case of a woman in armthorpe
had been beaten with a baseball bat by
burglars three years ago nobody had been
charged with that burglary and she
couldn't sleep at night under their
watch tragically that's not an unusual
case
so could the Prime Minister tell us
what's the charge rate for theft and
burglary across the country
Mr Mr Speaker actually since 2019
neighborhood crime is down by 25 percent
that we are on track to meet our Target
of doubling the number of rape cases
that are reaching our court since
since the rape review action plan was
published we've seen
referrals double we've seen charges
double and last year there was a 65
increase in rape convictions but
importantly we also change the law to
ensure that rapists would spend more
time in prison but what did his shadow
policing police at his shadow policing
Minister say prison doesn't prevent
crime it tells you everything that you
need to know about the labor party you
can't trust them to keep Britain safe
stands there and pretends that
everything's fine he is so totally out
of touch
he needs he needs to get out of
Westminster get out of Kensington
and Mr Speaker I don't think
it's a big day today in the house and
it's a very important day we do want to
make progress holding us up is not
Advantage as to any of us Mr Speaker he
needs to get out of wins Westminster get
out of Kensington
and I don't mean to Malibu to the
streets of Britain go there and tell
people it's all fine and see what
reaction he gets the answer he didn't
want to give although he knows it is
four percent of cases four percent of
burglary charges are charged 96 of theft
and burglary cases not even going before
the courts burglar is twice as likely to
get away with it now as they were a
decade ago they should be ashamed of
that record
sat in Armed Forces apparently seen 10
burglaries in 18 months but only one of
them has resulted in a prosecution so
rather than boasting and blaming others
why doesn't he tell the country when
he's going to get the theft and burglary
charge rate back to where it was before
they wrecked policing
[Applause]
can I say I
I like the lines as well but I prefer to
hear them the robberger come on
missed it
no then we
are Mr shelbrook will be buying the teas
in the Tea Room if we're not careful
and
they'll be Yorkshire tees Mr Speaker
but since Mr Speaker since the
conservatives came into Power crime is
down 50 Mr Speaker
violent crime down 40 burglary The
Honorable gentleman mentioned burglary
burglary down 56 why because we've
recruited 20 000 more police officers
we've given them the powers to tackle
crime and we've kept serious offenders
in prison for longer all they've done is
vote against greater protections for
emergency workers they've opposed
tougher sentences for violent criminals
and they are failing to give the police
the powers that they need it's the same
old labor soft on crime soft on
criminals
the only criminal investigation he's
ever been involved in is the one that
found him guilty of breaking the law
[Applause]
executed countless rapists
on that primary I I want tough
I am determined to hear the questions
whether it's the leader of the
opposition the prime minister so I can
sorry I think you'll be I think you've
got your first customer for tea Mr Kerns
we keep having this little problem we'll
have no more
know that just a book so please let's
get through and let's just show to some
respect to both people at dispatch boxes
thank you Mr Speaker I've prosecuted
countless rapists and I support tougher
sentences but you have to catch the
criminals first and when 98 of rapists
had not even been put before the court
that's a massive failure but if he wants
to go to arm Port which is in Yorkshire
why doesn't he go to that cul-de-sac
when he gets out and about Yorkshire and
and ask them about those 10 burglaries
that haven't been prosecuted the reality
is after 13 years of Tory government
they've done nothing on standards
neighborhood policing has been shattered
and birdless and rapists walk the
streets with impunity it's the same
every week from the Prime Minister
whether it's the cost of living crisis
try running out of control or the state
of the NHS why is this answer always to
tell this British people they've never
had it so good
[Music]
Mr Speaker let me just address that the
issue The Honorable gentleman raised
because I said at the time I respected
the decision the police reached and I
offered an unreserved apology but for
the avoidance of Doubt speaker at the
moment that happened there was a full
investigation by a very senior civil
servant
which confirms
had no Advanced knowledge about what had
been planned having arrived early for a
meeting that he doesn't need he doesn't
need me to tell him that he's probably
spoken to the report's author much more
frequently than I have
[Applause]
blue the Prime Minister needs to answer
the question he doesn't need you to
oh oh I don't think we need any more
let's keep it that way prime minister
Mr Speaker we're getting on we're
halving inflation by paying 50 of
people's energy bills and freezing for
your duty we cut it on and it's the same
for this side Mr Gwen I don't need any
more from the back benches here either
could I just say let's come
Mr Publican not again I'm just quite
seriously today is a very big day so
importantly since you're going to be
taken so please I want to get this house
moving on prime minister
Mr Speaker
NHS
[Applause]
yes we're stopping the boats with the
new bills
that's a conservative government
delivering on the people's priorities
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
friend the Prime Minister for the
efforts he has made to support the UK's
steel industry
tell him that we remain very concerned
about Job losses at British Steel in
scunthorpe so will he today reassure my
constituents in North Lincolnshire that
we will never see the end of UK still
making under his watch
Mr Speaker the UK steel industry can
have no greater Champion than my
honorable friend
and I know that this must be a
concerning time for British steel
employees and we stand ready to work
with her to support them now she's right
industrial sectors including steel have
been able to bid into competitive
government funds worth one billion
pounds to help support them to cut
emissions and become more energy
efficient and the government's recently
announced British industry supercharger
fund can help boost competitiveness in
UK's Key Energy intensive Industries and
I look forward to working with her to
ensure a thriving steel industry in our
United Kingdom the smps yeah
so thank you Mr Speaker I'd like to
begin by paying tribute to PC Palmer
who's so tragically lost his life
in defense of this Parliament and indeed
what we all stand for democracy
Mr Speaker what what is the prime
minister most about brexit right now is
it the likely four percent hit to UK
productivity or is it three former Tory
leaders planning to vote down his deal
this afternoon
oh Mr Speaker
Mr Mr Speaker that the Windsor The
Windsor framework The Windsor framework
represents
just just to help the chamber I
so help everybody I understand it's true
prime minister
Mr Mr Speaker The Windsor framework
represents a good deal for the people
and Families of Northern Ireland it
restores the balance of the Belfast Good
Friday agreement and ensures Northern
Ireland's place in our precious Union uh
but what I would say to him I was more
intrigued to see the words of his own
party's president who just this past
week have described his own party as
being in their words in a tremendous
mess
Stephen Flynn Mr Speaker the reality is
that whilst Westminster is once again
consumed by the damage being caused by
brexit the public at home are facing the
biggest fall in living standards ever
the highest tax burden since the end of
the second world war and inflation at
10.4 when are the conservative party and
indeed the labor party going to realize
that brexit can't work
Mr Speaker the actions that this
government are taking are ensuring that
fully half of most families energy bills
are being supported by this government
we're also making sure that we're
delivering for people with the cutting
NHS waiting lists and that's something
that we're happy to work with the
Scottish government to learn and share
best practice with them on but we're
also Mr Speaker delivering on the
people's number one priority which is to
stop the boats and end illegal migration
significantly over the last decade but
there are still vacancies to fill and
specific groups to help and on Monday
the employment Minister and I have
visited Arnold job center where it
Kelsey and a team are welcoming local
employees to speak directly to God
Seekers are dedicated over 50 plus work
coach is getting more from that bracket
into work so with my right to my friend
join me congratulations staff at Arnold
and other job centers across the country
on the proactive work that they're doing
and when time allows them to come to
visit Arnold Jobcentre in person it's in
a great way
[Applause]
or can I thank my honorable friend and
join him in thanking all the staff at
Arnold job center for their hard work I
shall keep his kind invitation to visit
in mind he mentioned the uh over 50s and
uh or emerged in the over 50s whereas my
honorable friend the chancellor describe
them are more experienced workers and he
was right to focus on them because
together with the work and pension
secretary we are putting in place a
range of measures to help support them
to return to and stay in the labor
market and that is something that not
only will help us continue to bring
inflation down but will support those
people to have healthy productive
fulfilling lives
because the UK government recently
confirmed that Scotland generated and
sent south 35 billion kilowatt hours of
energy in 2021 that number will rise to
124 billion in less than eight years
time for this multi-billion pound Bounty
Scotland will see no Revenue no
manufacturing or supply chain jobs in
our land of energy plenty why should our
people be cold and hungry and businesses
failing as a result of his government's
robbery so what has the prime minister
to say in defense of this naked
exploitation of Scotland's people and
its resources
Mr Mr Speaker actually this government
is a strong supporter of Scotland's
naughty oil and gas industry and
actually it's an economically illiterate
policy of I think almost all opposition
parties to prohibit any new exploration
of fossil fuels in the North Sea which
would have us then pay billions of
pounds to foreign energy companies and
then ship that energy here with twice
the carbon emissions it's a completely
absurd policy Mr Speaker that's bad for
all security it's bad for our economy
and that's why we're better off with the
conservatives
thank you very much again Mr Speaker the
island has been getting a better deal in
recent years and I thank the Prime
Minister for that especially before he
was a prime minister when he was working
with me in different roles in when he
was in government to make that happen
and I'm grateful however the island
Remains the only sizable island in the
UK without a fixed leak uh separated
from the mainland by sea which does not
receive a funding uplift to support
local government services and this
Injustice has been ongoing now for 50
years and all the evidence Mr Speaker
shows that it costs more to provide
local services on an island than on the
mainland will the Prime Minister work
with me and his ministers to overcome
this Injustice this year well can I
thank my honorable friend for his
continued campaigning on behalf of his
constituents it was a pleasure to spend
many happy childhood holidays on the
island and I enjoyed visiting him more
recently there as well the Isle of Wight
Council will benefit from a 10 increase
in their funding in cash term to the
next financial Year and have been
awarded an additional million pounds in
recognition of the unique circumstances
of the island as honorable friend points
out but I will ensure that he does get a
meeting with the minister for local
government to carry on the good work
that he and I started and make sure that
his local constituents get the support
that they need rev Stringer
Mr Speaker we now know from the
telegraph's lockdown files that during
covid at the very heart of government
science wasn't being followed and
rational discourse had been abandoned
uh this had dire consequences for
children's education mortality rates
amongst the elderly the economy and
access to the Health Service lessons
must be learned Mr Speaker but we can't
wait 10 years for the independent
inquiry to tell us what we should do
next time when the inevitable epidemic
arrives will the Prime Minister agree to
a short-term focused inquiry that can
give us recommendations so that we do
better next time
well Mr Speaker as with any public
inquiry the process and timing of the
inquiry stages are for the independent
chair to decide as baroness Hallett has
previously set out she intends to gather
written evidence throughout this year
with public hearings also starting this
year they held a preliminary hearing in
February which covered pandemic
preparedness and resilience and they've
set out dates for preliminary hearings
into core political and administrative
decision making across the UK for
throughout this month but most
importantly The Honorable gentleman will
recognize it is an independent inquiry
and it's for the independent chair to
set the terms
Mr Speaker more than one and a half
million people living outside London
stand to be impacted by the mayor's new
london-wide ultra low emission Zone
labor and the liberal Democrats they're
all for the US charge they don't care
about the cost of living crisis so does
my right honorable friend agree with me
that the best way to protect commuters
and small businesses from the spread of
this unfair 12 pound 50 a day tax is to
vote conservative on May the 4th
Mr Speaker my honorable friend is
absolutely right and and he I think he
also failed to mention that just this
week we've seen we've seen labor in
Wales introduce more plans for further
Road charging as well increasing cost
pressures for public and businesses and
I'd urge the party's opposite to listen
and stand up for the public and small
businesses just as the conservatives do
very much Mr Speaker when my brother was
diagnosed with ulcerative colitis eight
years ago it's fair to say it turned our
lives upside down I'm incredibly proud
of the manias and all that he's achieved
whilst living with this life-limiting
condition and my Livingston constituents
Stephen sharp manages local football
team the fushi and Sony Barn he has
Crohn's disease and he lives with a
stoma and he's like many of our
constictions up and down the UK living
with a life limiting condition trying to
provide for their families whilst
holding down jobs with a condition and
disease that wreaks havoc on their body
so Mr Speaker given one in four people
wait more than a year for diagnosis will
the Prime Minister and indeed the house
support the campaign to cut the crap and
get diagnosed their life for a Crohn's
and Colitis and would he meet with my
constituent Stephen and I to look look
at what more can be done for awareness
research and funding
can I Thank The Honorable lady for her
question and pay tribute to I think her
brother and also Stephen for everything
that they're doing to raise awareness of
this issue I'd be very happy to meet
with her and Stephen is is something
that I am familiar with and it is a very
difficult condition for people to live
with and it's right that they get the
support and attention that they deserve
and I look forward to that discussion
with her so Jeremy Wright thank you very
much Mr Speaker my constituent Jamie
Scott spent four weeks in a coma and
remained seriously disabled as a result
of a coveted vaccination he and his
family continue to believe that mass
vaccination is the right policy but it
must also surely be right to ensure that
those that tiny minority who are
seriously injured as a result are
properly compensated
in the absence of court cases it's in no
one's interests to litigate the current
limit on compensation is a hundred and
twenty thousand pounds even for very
serious and lifelong injury and anyone
who is disabled by less than 60 percent
gets nothing at all that cannot be right
well my right or my friend look urgently
at changing it
Mr Speaker it is important to start by
recognizing the importance of vaccines
in protecting us all and not least a
fantastic roll out of the covert
vaccines across the UK but I am very
sorry to hear about the case that my
right honorable friend raises in the
extremely rare case of a potential
injury from a vaccine covered by the
scheme a one-off payment can be awarded
this is not designed to be a
compensation scheme and it does not
prevent the injured person in pursuing a
legal compensation claim with the
vaccine manufacturer we are taking steps
to reform vaccine damage payment schemes
by modernizing the operations and
providing more timely outcomes but of
course I'll be happy to talk to The
Honorable gentleman further about them
thank you Mr Speaker the new inflation
stats this morning so food inflation is
at 18 the highest in 45 years millions
are living in food and fuel poverty
because of this government's failures
and political decisions to enable go
test profiteering at the expense of our
communities how on Earth can the Prime
Minister claim his plan is working or is
it in his eyes is it a success that so
many people are struggling with their
weekly food shop
Mr speakers if the Mr Speaker the
figures that have been recently
published showed that since 2010 there
are two million fewer people living in
poverty thanks to the actions of this
and previous conservative government of
course no one wants to see people
struggling with week-to-week bills like
fluid which is why it is so imperative
we stick to our economic plan and as the
obr have said we are on track to halve
inflation by the end of this year that
is the most important thing we can do to
ease a burden on people and in the
meantime we have a range of programs
whether that's free School meals or
indeed the holiday activities and food
program to provide support to the most
vulnerable families who need our help
thank you thank you Mr Speaker 60
million to improve transport links from
Wednesday the rest of 4 million for
wednesbury High Street and last week the
most important part of the budget the 22
and a half million pound to level up
Tipton Town Center Mr Speaker this
government has put vote of confidence in
my communities one they've not had for
nearly 50 years can I ask my honorable
friend delivery is going to be
absolutely key on these projects because
it can easily using his good office that
we absolutely get this delivered on time
and realize the potential of my
communities and tips
or can I pay tribute to my honorable
friend for his tireless campaigning on
behalf of his local communities I'm
delighted that we are investing across
the West Midlands but particularly in
places like wednesbury and Tipton and
again we will work with him to ensure
that those Investments are indeed
delivered working with the local
councils transport for West Midlands and
the West Midland combines Authority
those Investments are going to transform
people's lives and spread opportunity in
his area and he deserves enormous credit
for making that happen your mom's really
grateful Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
households in gateshead have seen in
their energy builds triple over the last
two years they've endured not just the
energy unit price increase but the daily
electricity standing charges increased
from an average of 22 pence in 2019 to
58 pence from next month an increase of
155 in standing charges over 200 pounds
per year to many of my constituents
particularly there was in low-income
households this seems like a company Tax
just for having the temerity to be
connected to the network and these
schemes will continue long after energy
support schemes have ended so will the
Prime Minister commit to ending the
regressive increases in standing charges
and in stroke off-chem the return of the
2019 levels or even end them completely
[Applause]
Mr Mr Speaker thanks to the chancellor
the government is providing support to a
typical household Energy bill around
half of that bill over the winter
support that was extended in the budget
and will be worth 1 500 pounds to a
typical family but we went further Mr
Speaker for those most vulnerable
families was a chance to announce we
will be ending the discrepancy between
unit charges for those on prepayment
meters something that many in this house
have called for and also providing
generous cost of living payments worth
900 pounds to the most vulnerable
families
thank you Mr okay Mr Speaker two of my
constituents George and Carol Ellis are
my guests here in the gallery today so
2021 their son died by Suicide George
was a member of the Yorkshire regiment
and had become depressed uh following uh
a comp one of his comrades who had taken
his own life in memory of George uh
Adrian and Carol have set up a support
group which marries up one veteran uh
with another who is able to talk through
and hopefully help them
uh the uh support group is called get
your get emotions out
after George would the Prime Minister
join me in offering condolences to
Adrian and Carol and also his support
for the work that they're now doing
can I join my honorable friend in
sending mine the whole House's
condolences to George's friends and
family and thank his parents for the
brave work they are doing to raise
awareness of veterans Mental Health
support is available for anyone
experiencing suicidal thoughts including
from the Samaritan's helpline and thanks
to the excellent work of my honorable
friend the veterans Minister we are
working specifically to support veterans
mental health through op courage which
is a bespoke mental health and wellbeing
service for veterans in the NHS back by
considerable funding which was increased
in the recent budget and that fully
Integrated Service will be launched next
month but again I pay tribute to
George's parents for all the incredible
work that they are doing yeah
thank you Mr Speaker my Constitution
Mariam Amiri came to the UK from
Afghanistan on a special on a special
Visa back in 2016. the home office have
just refused to Renewal and advise she
should return to Afghanistan
Mariam is an educator due to start a
university course in September she's a
value Community activist she's a vocal
opponent of the Taliban she is married
to a man who worked for British forces
and her family is currently being
persecuted in Afghanistan she's been
trying to get them here since
Afghanistan fell can the Prime Minister
think of any barriers or hardships Mary
might face in returning to a country
where there is not even any means of
applying for a Visa and will he
personally intervene as the immigration
Minister has yet to reply to me despite
raising this three weeks ago
Mr Speaker obviously it wouldn't be
appropriate for me to comment on an
individual's Visa case but I will ensure
I will ensure I will ensure that The
Honorable lady gets a response from the
home office with regard to that
particular case Lynn Shakespeare you Mr
Speaker
can I ask the prime minister to pay
tribute to and congratulate my
constituent Max woozy best known as the
boy in the tent whose three-year
Adventure camping outside is drawn to
occur guys today he has raised over
three quarters of a million pounds for
the excellent North Devon hospice and
will my my honorable friend wish
everyone taking part in his final
Adventure a camping festival at
broomhill estate great success
can I join honorable friend in paying
tribute to Max and everyone else taking
part in this fantastic initiative and
congratulate them on raising such a
considerable sum of money for a very
worthy local local cause and I look
forward to hearing how the rest of it
goes but very well done final question
thank you Mr Speaker well how the
treasure receives an industrial 65
Belgian revenue from Scotland's oil and
gas they've only allocated 20 billion
for carbon capture but nothing for
Scotland they've cut renewable energy
budget by Third they've only allocated
10 million pounds from Scotland's World
leading title stream and filter back
pump storage Hydro but yet they want us
to contribute our share towards a 35
billion size we see nuclear power
station isn't it the case that within
the union Scotland is the energy that
Westminster takes the powers yeah
Mr Speaker not only are we supporting
Scotland's North Sea oil and gas
industry we're also providing 20 billion
pounds of funding for further carbon
capture and storage and does want to
work and provide Clarity for acorn
regarding their future path but also I
think the honorable gentleman raised the
issue of tidal power and I am pleased to
tell him that actually that is now
included in the contracts for different
allocations and there's 40 megawatts of
new tidal stream Power by four projects
across Scotland and Wales in the last
year that's this government delivering
energy security across the United
Kingdom
complete questions